over 60 percent of all positions for
information workers
spend more than 30 of their time doing
rote automatable work
isn't it time for a change robotic
process automation is revolutionizing
the speed of business
automating processes creates great
economic benefits for companies
and even more importantly they unburden
employees from some of their most boring
and time-consuming tests
with 66 of companies planning on
increasing
rpa spend in 2020 jobs and robotic
process automation
are poised to explode as companies
explore the efficiencies
and savings that rpa provides now's the
time to get ahead of the curve
enroll in udacity's rpa developer
nanodegree program
made in partnership with uipath to help
automate everyday
tasks in this program you'll first learn
the skills for how to enable automation
processes
and familiarize yourself with how to
implement them on the uipath platform
from there you'll master specific
automation techniques
for the most commonly used applications
like excel
emails and pdfs to do this
you will dive deeper into common
processes design
debugging deployment exception handling
and best practices in all of these areas
finally you will work within the uipath
platform to implement
rpa best practices and enable more
advanced
automation processes at the end of this
program
you'll have a portfolio of projects to
show potential employers your newfound
skill set
unlock the potential of any job and
accelerate your impact enroll in
udacity's rpa developer
nanodegree program today